whether or not you've already finished
blood-borne and are starting on your new
game+ playthrough there's a good chance
some of the game's more obscure
mechanics may have passed you by here
are seven of the best that should help
you master blood-borne number one you
can attack while climbing a ladder press
r1 to punch upward or r2 to kick
downward just don't run out of stamina
while you're on the ladder or you'll
fall to your death
number two your trick weapon
transformation is also an attack if
you're in the middle of attacking an
enemy you can press l1 to perform an
attack that also transforms your weapon
into its other mode at the same time
stylish number three you can restore the
health lost from creating blood bullets
if you press up on the d-pad to create
blood bullets the regain system
activates and you can restore that
health cost by attacking the nearest
enemy it's basically free ammo number
four you can add gestures to your notes
when writing a note press r1 a couple of
times to find more options you can add a
second set of words and a gesture this
is great for the point gesture as it
saves the direction you're looking in
when you start writing the note as such
it's possible to literally point out
secrets
number five you can break out of
gravattack's if you quickly alternate
pressing l2 and r2 you can break out of
a grab slightly quicker you'll also
break out of it without getting knocked
down and can immediately run away or
start attacking number six you can
reassign the controls the ps4 is latest
update allows you to reassign controls
through the accessibility option under
settings
I recommend moving the circle button
over to l1 that way you can sprint and
dodge while retaining full camera
control on the right stick which is
great when fighting blood bonds larger
bosses and finally tip number seven you
can regain help from dying enemies if
you've just killed an enemy and the
regain system is still active hitting an
enemy during their death animation will
still siphon health out of them so go
ahead match that attack button for all
its work